le projet de loi de réforme des
universités sera présenté au conseil des
ministres le 25 juin il doit remplacer
la loi savary le ministre délégué à
l'enseignement supérieur à la devaquet
on a révélé dès aujourd'hui les grandes
lignes un projet plus modérée que prévu
on est loin des universités à
l'américaine dont on parlait au mois
d'avril
le maître mot reste l'autonomie mais
alain devaquet a tout de suite mis
quelques bémols écoutez je voudrais
qu'il soit bien compris que le mot
autonomie ne signifie pas liberté totale
comme si les universitaires était d'une
certaine façon propriétaire de
l'université pas question donc pour les
universités de fixer des droits
d'inscription prohibitifs ou de trier
les meilleurs bacheliers
par contre les universités pourront à
côté des diplômes nationaux qui sont
maintenus créer leurs propres diplômes
spécifiques et si dans les conseils
d'université les professeurs retrouve
une place prépondérante la loi devaquet
ne va pas plus loin que la loi savary
sur les possibilités de financement
privé des universités
le projet de loi que nous avait d'abord
il permet et bien entendu ses
possibilités il mentionne parmi les
ressources possibles et dons et legs
mais la décision ne relève pas d'une loi
sur la science url relève d'une loi de
finances